but do you remember back in the day when
people used to like they call it
twerking now but like grinding right now
grinding right there's definitely
grinding going on now that we think
about it we would do that in middle
school yeah it's so weird to think of
middles yeah middle school and even i
don't know freshman in high school
feeling like tiny little boners and yeah
[ __ ] dancing they weren't all tiny
either
but they were in high school and so was
i when we're out and we're drinking at
one point he's like so what's a nice
girl like you doing out with a guy like
me oh god what about yourself and i was
like
what the [ __ ]
and i was like wait what
what does that mean why is that so funny
well i was like what are you doing yeah
who are you yeah what do you mean like
what do you
but after the movie date he took me to
jack in the box drive-through to get
dinner
and then at the parking lot of the jack
in the box as we were eating our dollar
menu items as we were eating our
menu items
he's
showing me the marine songs and chanting
to them
oh
god where's the card where's the card oh
well yeah you can go ahead i don't even
need to tell any stories
[ __ ]
there is nothing gonna top that
seriously i gotta finish i'm not done
[Music]
hi welcome back to another episode of
big moon
hi everyone how's it going uh hi it's me
gina
it's me jess
it's stiff you copied us the thing that
you hated well it's only after two then
it becomes like a [ __ ] rhythm and
then that pisses me so if i went next
and then she did it that would have been
a big yeah true okay um welcome back we
are playing another game because i'm
great at moderating these is my [ __ ]
here we're letting gina take over the
show and gina likes to play games she is
a professional gamer yeah so the game is
called best story wins it's uh from our
friends over at dss the ones who made
drunk stone stupid they sent me a bunch
of games and i was like these are fun
like just send me all these because
these will be fun for our podcast and
it's a game called best story wins where
i pull a topic card and each of us tells
a story that either happens to them or
that they know of and uh whoever has the
best story wins the card whoever at the
end has the most cards wins now i went
and i pulled a bunch of cards so you
guys don't have to see us like shuffling
through cards that are irrelevant to us
i went and pulled a bunch of cards and i
feel that
we would have stories for and very
interesting stories for and some of
these might be really embarrassing
but it'll be fun to listen to so
um i'm going to preface this by saying i
have terrible memory recall so if i kind
of like
back out of one or two i just really
can't remember
okay or you can tell other people's
stories or if one person doesn't have it
we'll choose between two
first card says
the weirdest moment that involved urine
that was not my own
oh i really don't want to tell this
she hasn't store i have a story for this
and i don't really want to say it out
loud oh i want to hear this just in case
anyone that i know in my life actually
hears this you can change the name of
said person's urine story
so a girl i knew
i can't say that you can tell a story
i can't tell this publicly i'll tell you
guys after do you have one oh [ __ ] i was
so invested in her
uh urine that wasn't my urine mm-hmm i
just keep thinking of cat pee i don't
know why
it could be or my like my baby's pee
yeah
he accidentally peed on you or something
no it's funny because he both of my kids
have peed on themselves like it's pretty
funny because they have boys
like when they lay on the channel yeah
exactly yeah like and they just start
peeing yeah yeah but no that's not good
enough we need to we need a good one
i have one
um it was new year's one day and we had
just all gotten back from our new year's
celebration and we were all like just we
got in the airbnb to crash in i was
sleeping on the couch and my guy friend
was sleeping on the other couch
and it was just me and him in the living
room
we were drinking that night
and
in the middle of night because i can't
sleep in the middle of the night he got
up and i was like oh [ __ ] what's up dude
you okay and he didn't respond he was
mumbling
he walked over to the dresser that he
was gonna pee on you oh she's crazy i'll
punch his dick off
he walked up to the to the dresser
unzipped his pants and just started
peeing on the dresser he was like
drawing sleepwalk peeing i have this i
have a similar story to that yeah and i
was like oh [ __ ] what is he doing i went
to i ran to the bathroom i grabbed a
bunch of towels you cleaned his pee i
didn't pee but i like laid it down
while he was peeing oh my god he was
like peeing on the towel also and i like
grabbed more towels and i threw it on
there and he like drunkenly stumbled
back to bed and fell asleep whose place
was this it was an airbnb oh my god and
i was like trying to prevent my friends
from getting like fined or whatever yeah
so i like was it an airbnb that we put
in our names no no no no thank god this
was in the bay area and then the next
morning he woke up and i was like dude
do you remember what you did he's like
no no and i showed him and i told him
blankets yeah and i was like he's like
oh my god and
i like i was like i'm not going to say
anything like i don't want to embarrass
him in front of his friends he's like
thank you but then here i am telling it
on podcasts
yeah so it's one of my ex-boyfriends
like we got so wasted one night and just
and we were just staying in his room and
i remember he got up and he peed in his
trash can well i did it myself oh and it
wasn't sleeping i just really had to pee
but i couldn't go to the bathroom and my
sister was like just pee in the trash
but she was just
she was just like
helping my other sister who was also
really drunk she was the one sober one
so she was just pissed that like she had
to babysit us i was 13 by the way she's
so [ __ ]
yeah i got
me and my uh my sister we got so wasted
off of like these quinceanera tequilas
so like
over there
everyone like for as a gift or what are
they called like a goodie bag kind of
thing or
what are they called yeah whatever you
know like a favorite bag that one yeah
as a favor or favor or whatever
frequency yeah they give guests tequilas
that are it's a 15 year old's birthday
party yeah but this is guadalajara where
it's the town like the state of jalisco
tequila is in that state
so ever they get bottles of tequila as
favors and it has like the girl's
birthday on it and like her face and
like her name whatever it's like
personalized to the girl the point is my
grandma had she has a collection of them
and her and her like cupboard from all
the concealers she's been to so then my
sister and i grabbed one and we just got
so we finished half the bottle between
both
that was the first time i was getting
drunk too like your first time yeah the
first time
and yeah four years ago
like the back of my throat no for years
if i even just thought of the word
tequila maybe you want to throw up but
anyway so yeah i was just so wasted and
and we were in the bedroom trying to be
so quiet because we didn't want my
grandma to know that we were so drunk
and i had to pee but in order to pee i
have to get out and
get caught i don't like
to get into my grandma yeah so my sister
was like just be on the bus in the trash
can and i was wearing these high
high-waisted pants they had like a
million buttons
and i couldn't unbutton them in time so
i just sat in the trash can and i just
peed in my pants oh my god
yeah and i was just like well here here
we are so he peed through the denim yeah
through my black high-waisted
million button pants oh my god and i
remember my dad had just given me money
too he gave me like 200 bucks and i had
them in my back pocket oh no and they
disappeared i don't know because i left
my pants there and my grandma was
watching them someone took someone
your cousin stole your money yeah or
something but anyway the next morning
was my flight back home and it was like
at 7 00 a.m
and oh i had it
yeah i was so hungover
so the previous day of the day that we
got drunk it was my uncle's birthday
party and they had made bionicos which
is like this fruit dish that you put
like bionicles y'all are making little
robots it's like um condensed milk over
fruit and like toppings that was really
bomb
anyway the next day when we're heading
towards the airport i keep throwing up
and my other uncle not the one that was
his birthday party my other uncle was
like you're [ __ ] hungover aren't you
and he's like
and i'm like no no uncle just the
bionicles just were really bad like i
keep throwing up to bionicles like i
just they just hit me really bad
how would that even be a possible answer
it was a dessert yeah
that was my 13 year old excuse and he's
like you're [ __ ] like i don't buy it
oh my god and then i was like oh and i
kept throwing up right so i threw up on
a jacket so in the airport i just in the
plane i just smell like vomit oh god no
okay you know what maybe it's okay
technically it says technically it's not
your own yeah so i think she
disqualifies
a better story well it's a better story
i'll give you that card really yeah you
even though you can't yeah yeah
volume in front of family and lost money
and you can yeah yeah that's
my story might have won but i'm not
going to tell it so oh god this one out
wait can you tell can we pause and then
tell this off-camera i'll tell you when
we're for sure off camera back okay fine
because casey is like damaged
i'm so curious about the story now
all right next one my most memorable
high school dance story high school
dance like the dances at the high school
gosh i only went to one
um i have one it was homecoming i think
junior or senior year
and i was going with my friend alvin who
like we were kind of flirting back and
forth like the year before so for
homecoming we went together
um
and i had gone to the bathroom
okay no well yeah okay so um let's
preface this um beginning of the school
year there's a new girl that came to
school her name was lucy i think and she
was like i i felt bad for her she was
like the sweet girl so i showed her
around i introduced her to people
and you know she was my friend and then
homecoming comes and alva and i go to
homecoming together
and
i was like okay hold on i'll be back i'm
gonna go to the bathroom i go to the
bathroom i come out and he's dancing
with lucy and i was like
what the [ __ ]
he said oh what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
oh what the [ __ ] you know because like
in high school like when you go to
dances together you don't like dance
with other girls yeah guys you know like
the same
exactly being my date
and i was standing there for a little
bit like
and he kept on dancing with her i was
like okay
that's it you're about to go pull some
hair no
left
you just left yeah i left i lived like
really close about that i just went home
okay um and then like
a week later at school
she was like is she like after school we
were standing on the steps and she was
like hey i heard that you're mad at me
and then i was like yeah because you
danced with my date even though you knew
that i liked him we were like you and i
were friends i told you and you were
dancing with my date
like that's really [ __ ] up dude what
the [ __ ] is your problem she started
crying and i was like all right whatever
i don't know whatever happened to her
afterwards i don't remember seeing her
anymore but
she killed herself
i'm just kidding i'm kidding
i'm like you're a bully and she killed
herself
she probably like moved schools or
something she's like i can't i can't
deal with this high school oh my god um
but alvin and i like we're friends now
sometimes they'll pop into my chat and
stream and i'll call them out in front
of my whole chat like oh you
[ __ ] you want to show your face
here yeah
like how did he react after you left or
like what happened he apologized he was
really sweet about he's like i'm so
sorry i shouldn't have done that i was
like yeah cool whatever but then my
crush from died after that we were just
friends afterwards um but like we're
friends you know
now he pops in and chat every once in a
while so what happened where you used to
see a red flag and then just fall off
and then now you see a red flag and you
stick around trauma
[Laughter]
um
so now i just give him [ __ ] whenever he
comes into jail he's like you're never
going to let this down or let me get
this down i'm like nope
i can be 80 years old you show up to my
weddings later on or something i don't
know what the [ __ ] don't you dare
dance with anyone else even at my own
wedding yeah exactly how dare you he's
like dancing with your grandma you're
like how dare you
you got my name is lucy i leave my
wedding
i'm going home it's right on the street
yeah so that's my um yeah that's my
that's my uh my dancing your high school
dance story god damn
high school wait it has to be high
school because i have a middle school
story yeah that works i mean not really
a story
i don't know it's just a memory like i
remember going to my eighth grade dance
and
[ __ ] i think about it now and i'm like
holy [ __ ] we were so young doing this
but do you remember back in the day when
people used to like they call it
twerking now but like grinding
grinding
there's definitely grinding going on now
that we think about it we would do that
in middle school yeah it's so weird to
think of middles yeah middle school and
even i don't know freshmen in high
school feeling like tiny little boners
and yeah [ __ ] dancing they weren't
all tiny either
but they were in high school and so was
i i remember girls i'm thinking i'm
talking about middle school girl i
remember bragging about it in middle
school like oh yeah i was grinding on
him and i felt him get hard and like now
that i think i'm like oh y'all are 12.
yeah yeah
you weren't even ready to have that
inside of you shut up yeah you've only
been able to get bonus for like a year
or so
it's [ __ ] weird man
yeah it just makes me feel so
uncomfortable
thinking that especially like me at this
age where it feels like it feels wrong
to remember that yeah at that age it's
so weird that's why like my dad is like
my dad would be like no your brother
like wouldn't watch porn or whatever
he's only 12 years old i'm like that's
when they start yeah
hello i have another dance memory um so
the only high school dance i went to was
my freshman winter formal that's it just
one day the only day i went to my whole
well i missed a whole year out of the
four years yeah it was my second half of
sophomore and my first half of junior i
was in mexico so i missed a good chunk
of regular high school
and anyway so that dance that i went to
i went with my friend
and his name was ibsen
and so ibsen was like that's a noise
huh that's a certain noise noise it's a
sound ibsen
but yeah
he was really nice like super super kind
and i think it's in the bible oh what
the [ __ ] how is that an autumn appeal
i'm saying it's a weird sounding name
she might as well just be a noise
sounds like gibson
oh yeah
so anyway he was like super gentlemanly
he got me my corsage and everything like
we like a whole bunch of friends got a
limo and
my winter formal was at knott's berry
farm so we got to have the whole park
for us and ride the rides and it was
really fun
but the
part that i kind of like
giggle a little bit it's really immature
but it's the fact that he was
significantly shorter than me oh so
during our photos for because you know
you take pictures
they had him stand
on a box i think he was like on an apple
box like an apple box
and had me step back oh wait step back
step forward yeah oh yeah i can't
remember that one forward tall person
steps back yeah yeah so they had to like
play some tricks to like make him look
like at a higher gun on your knees right
he wasn't that short
and he also had a cast too by the way
which was just like really a memorable
photo yeah you know what i mean this is
a dorky high school kid or a middle
school kid yeah but i look back on that
dance and thinking like that was really
special because it was my only high
school dance that i went to and also
like just with him like just being
so much shorter than me but also with
his cast like dancing with his cast was
like kind of awkward but i don't know it
was kind of cool and
years later
and it gets kind of sad but years later
here we go
here we go
he did die oh [ __ ] me god damn yeah okay
he was in a motorcycle accident ugh
yeah it's like an endearing memory like
a sweet yeah so when i have my shoe box
of pictures every time i i come across
my little winter formal picture i'm
always like oh
no
yeah no motorcycles yeah
okay wait who gets that card
damn it i feel like you should get the
cards out of like wait what's your high
school story i don't really i so i went
to like two dances every year so i've
been to like eight high school dances
and i don't remember anything [ __ ]
interesting happening at any of them i
was like on the homecoming court my
junior year what is that that's like
familiar oh like homecoming queen king
runner-up princess whatever so like only
the seniors
only the senior class can actually be up
for the king or queen i guess so there's
like a whole but there's a whole court
of people that are like freshman
sophomores juniors and seniors get voted
in by the high school to just be on the
court but then only the senior level
people
could win
whatever you just get i think you're
just on you're just courted i guess so
you're like on the court for i don't
know what the [ __ ] the point of it was
well like you
pick your date like whoever gets voted
in then picks their date so then of
course i picked a basketball player that
i was dating at the time but um nothing
i don't remember anything interesting
happening like i just had very basic
high school dances like there was
nothing like no fun drunk story that i
can recall
nothing nothing hmm i think you get this
one too out of sweet endearing story
that's adorable yeah what was the wait
what was yours uh uh alvin i voted gina
yeah really just keep it i vote you okay
he was dancing with some girl you can at
least get that card i text him i mean
[ __ ] you
he's gonna be like you talked about the
story again yeah
by the way thank you for touching you
yeah i saw you put your arm on her
shoulder
[ __ ] lucy um okay next one
like i never saw her again
i liked her i like that she just
disappeared not real girlfriend but
still acting like a girlfriend
dude it's been 20 years
um a time i snuck in somewhere snuck
into somewhere
i feel like you must have a story to
this snuck in
somewhere snuck into a movie snuck into
a concert snuck into a festival snuck
into the festival
okay i literally follow all the rules
come on
you're boring
these games are not good for me i don't
have any like memories of anything cool
damn it
yeah really you're sneaking away
in your house
i did sneak out of my house and then
back into my house yeah that's the story
there we go there's not much of a story
i just like so it well it was a little
more difficult because at the time my
dad was dating a woman who had a
daughter and so we had to share a room
all of a sudden so we had two beds in my
bedroom and i think she kind of woke up
or something and i was like she was like
in her little stupor of like kind of
being awake like where are you going and
i had to like
basically bribe her not to i'm a demon
i'll kill you
like bribery not telling me but anyway
so i just left and i like went and hung
out with my boyfriend and our friends
like
on the beach like because i grew up in a
beach town so we just like drove around
on the beach and have fun [ __ ] around
and had a party
but yeah and then so i snuck back inside
i don't recall
i don't know if they found out i don't
remember getting in trouble for it so
either i never got in trouble for it or
i didn't get into enough trouble to
remember uh i snuck into a festival a
rave once back then they used to call it
massives
they don't call it that
there's no festivals now uh this was two
thousand that sounds so european by
masses
um it was i think 2008 i was like 18
years old and my friend and i
was like had tickets but we saw how long
the [ __ ] line was to get in and we're
like yeah we already took our drugs it's
gonna kick in soon we gotta get inside
quick
and then we saw like this this group of
people like standing by it was like
these these these fences um with like
security guards standing inside and like
meeting a group of people and like our
me my friend and a group of people kind
of like we all kind of had the same idea
we saw him and we were like
hey what if each of us gave you like 10
or 20 bucks and you just let us in
through the back here
and he's like yeah because it's just
like you're like 20. he's like i don't
give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you could literally burn this place
down he wouldn't care you know
so we gave money no loyalty to these
people exactly
um they underpay me yeah absolutely
he doesn't care about those people yeah
so yeah we gave him the money and then
he opened up the gate but he didn't tell
the people the rest of security that was
beyond us or be on him
he's like you're gonna have to pay them
too yeah so they started chasing us and
it was me my friend tony tony and i
started [ __ ] running and um we ran
into the la coliseum which is it looks
it's like amphitheater seating right so
we run in and we turn and we run towards
the seats and just sit down
and then the security guard ran past us
nice the adrenaline you must have felt
in that moment
and drugs i like yours the one that you
told me when you stuck back into your
house and your mom was sleeping on your
bed waiting for you that one's funny but
i do have other sneaking in stories so
i've snuck into the vatican
what yeah casey and i were excuse me
yeah it was so cool
blasphemous
no so we were in italy and it was we did
an entire backpacking tour throughout
all of italy
it was so fun it was like two weeks that
we were gone and so finally we made it
to rome
and then this was already towards the
end of our trip so we're tired we're
like oh my god let's just let's just
knock out these sightseeing places like
i was just chill so
somehow it ended up being on easter
weekend and so
at the vatican it's literally like
christmas
and easter that's like the busiest times
of the year
with the most amount of people from all
over the world
that get there and so the entire like
plaza is completely packed with people
like super mega [ __ ] pack clearly
pre-coded and so it was insanely packed
and so we could hear like the church
bells and like the pope giving like the
sermon or whatever they call it like the
you know the church thing the mass
that's what it's called
[Music]
she's talking to a massive also
wow you guys stories are so similar
yeah and so like he finishes the mass
and he goes inside so we i didn't get to
see the pope but
as everyone's like leaving the gates
were open for like a sea of people and
so casey and i were like [ __ ] they're
gonna close the gates and we're not
going to be able to get in after like
this because people are like okay yeah
everyone's going home so then we went
around and there's like at the vatican
there's like a whole bunch of columns
and it's a it's a circle so like as soon
as you pass one column like you can't
see the other one so like you kind of
lose
the sight of the security guards at the
gate
so then we went past a few columns and
we're like okay let's do this jump it so
we jumped the fence and we're like oh my
god we snuck into the bed again
so we got to go inside and saw like st
peter's basilica and it was
massive it was freaking huge like the
biggest church i've ever seen in my
entire life i'm like how did humans
build this yeah it's crazy especially so
long ago yeah so no it was really cool
though we still got to like at least go
in and experience it and see it because
yeah as like they were waiting for the
sea of people to leave like we got to
experience
viewing everything oh we also saw the
sistine chapel oh
during that time yeah yeah but it was
all because we snuck in like they
weren't letting oh remember you had to
have a ticket in order to get in these
tickets were free but you had to have a
ticket to go in and they were no longer
just to i guess keep track of how many
people were there like to con like crowd
control i guess but because it was
already like the day of and like that
moment
people had already left so you counter
balanced it yeah that's that's why we
had to sneak in because we didn't have a
ticket even though they were free okay
so i think tiff wins because one should
commit a grand cardinal sin
she's going to hell
uh and three she committed an
international crime so that's all you
international crime
that's all you thank you they're gonna
come extradite you back tonight
i don't know i think it just feels like
yeah like the idea of trespassing to me
is like
you know we also broke more rules when
we were looking at the sistine chapters
banged in there we weren't allowed to
take pictures but we kept sneaking
pictures oh she lost two pictures nope
oh they don't need to take pictures
interesting
but i have a ton of selfies with the
sistine chapel
worth it it's gonna help does your
probiotic contain clinically studied
strains meet one that does ritual
symbiotic plus contains two of the
world's most studied strains with over
350 publications of human clinical
trials i chose ritual and symbiotic plus
because i like to take care of my
lady parts and my guts and it helps out
a lot so what makes a component so
clearly ritual there are science-backed
and research stacked especially when
stacked up against the leading direct to
consumer and top-selling probiotics on
the market it's more than a probiotic
it's a three-in-one with clinically
studied prebiotics probiotics and
postbiotic to support a balanced gut
microbiome the best part is it's only
one daily capsule for simple streamlined
gut support and it tastes like mint you
also don't need to refrigerate this it's
designed with moisture controlled bottle
technology to protect probiotic strains
symbiotic plus and ritual are here to
celebrate and not hide your insides
there's no more shame in your gut game
that's why ritual is offering listeners
10 off during your first three months
visit ritual.com big mood to start
ritual or add symbiotic plus to your
subscription today again that's
ritual.com
big mood for 10 off your first three
months
all right and i want to give a shout out
to our sponsor studs oh my goodness they
have the cutest earrings ever they sent
us over and i
am so obsessed i literally have not
removed my mini chunky huggies since i
received them they're gold and they're
so cute they're so durable and these
earrings are so comfortable i've
literally been wearing them to sleep i
shower with them they have not faded
they are so high quality i highly
recommend them it's pretty cool because
studs also have locations
around the us where you can actually go
and get yourself pierced so if you're
really afraid of getting a first-time
piercing you don't need to fear because
they only use single-use needles they
never use guns so it's way safer and way
better especially for advanced piercings
as well
studs earrings are made from high
quality materials which won't turn your
skin green plus they're lightweight and
durable enough for you to wear them all
the time like i've been
and you can even sleep and work out in
them as well like i've mentioned i am
such a big fan of these earrings studs
has over 250 styles of hoops huggies
studs cuffs and dangles and they pierce
way more than just lobes so it's easy to
create a statement look or something you
can keep in every day starting at just
ten dollars per earring studs is
reimagining the piercing experience for
each and every year you want to refresh
your look with a new piercing or need
pro styling advice you can shop online
or stop into studs in la new york city
austin nashville miami boston or seattle
with more locations coming soon right
now studs is offering our listeners 20
off your first purchase when you go to
studs.com
big mood
go to studs.com
big mood for 20 off your first purchase
that's studs.com
big mood and get yourself some cute
earrings or a new piercing
biggest waste of money oh i do that okay
i got something yeah let's hear this
i guess wasted money um
gosh i don't know i've spent on a lot of
stuff
what do you consider a waste though
because like if you get some fun out of
it or if you're enjoying yourself
i guess like if you look back at it now
like oh where did i [ __ ] buy that for
stupid i have a lot of those oh yeah
you're like the [ __ ] kickstarter
queen
oh yeah i spend money on the dumbest
things that i think it's like cool this
is next level it's going to make my life
so much easier is there anything else
that's still outstanding because we know
your peanut butter pump never came in is
there anything else you're getting email
updates from this man
promising me my pump i've changed my
address three times in like the [ __ ]
five years since i paid for it
yeah it's i'm still i'm still anything
else i'm gonna get my peanut butter pump
any other wasteful kickstarter uh yeah
so the one that pisses me off the most
is this um
it's this carry-on suitcase that i
bought
that
like the only thing it did is that i
could sit on it like
what i don't know why i thought it had a
little stool
i don't know why i bought oh no there's
another one that pisses me off too but
yeah this one it was just like it's just
like a hard case carry-on luggage that
you can sit on but to open it i broke so
many [ __ ] nails trying to open this
stupid-ass suitcase it was the dumbest
thing ever and then plus i sit on it and
because you're supposed to sit on it and
be able to roll like yourself though you
have to kiss yourself excuse me this is
before
yeah this is before the electric one
came out so i was like
really like early adopter yeah
and it didn't like it kind of sunk a
little bit like it was a piece of [ __ ]
it was a piece of [ __ ] product yeah
another one was like these earbuds that
i paid for like 200 bucks that are
supposed to be like
translating like it's supposed to
translate oh language i think i've seen
that commercial yeah i don't know it
doesn't work this was years ago well the
thing is it's so stupid because you have
to have an app right for this thing to
work but if you're speaking to someone
else they also have to have the options
the [ __ ] i wanted like real because the
way they sell it is like real time
translating
and now i think the technology is
probably there maybe i don't know but
years ago like at least like five six
years way too ahead of this time i and i
paid 200 bucks for these [ __ ] earbuds
they suck oh yeah i don't know there's
so many i have you're just a believer in
technology though yeah i believe in
innovation
your money on shitty products though
like pushes technology forward yeah like
the fact that you're willing to yeah
[ __ ] like that and like give people an
incentive to like try new things
beta test things yeah it moves their
world forward so that's not a tool you
know a lot of these products that i
wasted my money on was back when i used
to look at facebook like i never open
the app anymore because it's garbage
the victim of facebook advertising yeah
like those facebook ads really got me
and now it's instagram ads like my
nursing cover but no this nursing cover
is on point i [ __ ] love it so much
but yeah i bought it because it's an
instagram ad ads just get me and it
scares me because i'm like
you're the best target dude ever since i
was a child and you know how like the
jingles that they would have in the
commercials i knew i memorized every
single one i would always try to get my
mom to purchase things all the time and
then isaac when isaac was getting to
that age and he's like hey mom check
this out like there's this really cool
thing and i'm like oh my son
we are related and now you have 500
yeah but i always i was like i can't
wait till i'm an adult i'm gonna buy all
these things and i did
and i did that's adorable
uh i think my waste of money now it's
like why'd i buy all those designer [ __ ]
for it's like yeah isn't it like an
investment my chanel is everything else
things that you can resell
chanel always like appreciate some value
that's fine but like other [ __ ] like my
gucci bag is useless
useless they don't appreciate in value
well maybe not appreciate but they don't
entirely lose their value i don't even
care about them anymore or like yeah
they don't you could probably sell them
for like 70 percent probably
but now i'm like i don't really give a
[ __ ] about designer stuff anymore i
don't know why the [ __ ] i was like
caught up in the hype of buying like
expensive
fancy [ __ ]
just dumb and now i just carry holsters
around all day
i haven't worn my purses in so long
they're all dusty you could you could
sell them on like offer up or thread up
or whatever those [ __ ] things are
something up what was yours um big waste
of money
i don't know because like i i've blown
money for sure
but i always felt like money well spent
money well spent yeah even though it
wasn't necessarily i guess it depends on
your i mean there's like when i look
back at like certain ways that i've
decorated my apartments where i like
months later i hated it and then like
had to be kind of like from scratch like
kind of like where i was like finding
myself
in like my style i feel like i
definitely wasted a lot of money on like
in interior decorating stuff and i see
that you have never wasted money on that
because you don't decorate at all i
don't the thing is i really want to you
just have to operator
my room looks like because like i my
aesthetic changed too yeah i'm kind of
jealous of the fact that like i went
through all these phases these growth
phases of like trying to figure out my
style and you didn't kind of like you
did you haven't or you haven't yet like
you haven't gone through like burning
thousands of dollars like i hate this
couch now or like i hate this artwork
now or like that's one thing that i can
see because like
in my style i feel like it changes so
fast too and maybe it's just because
trends change so fast where i'm like i
have yet to like build a space that i
love like everything in my apartment now
if i could just like wash it all out and
like start over again i would but that's
thousands of dollars for beds couches
artwork like all this stuff it's so
expensive and so that's probably the one
thing where i'm like kind of frustrated
that i did spend money on yeah because
like my cars like i had that bmw for a
little while but like because i got such
a good deal on it when i turned it back
in i got all this money back so
basically like i drove it for six or
seven months and it was like
eight or nine hundred dollars a month
for the payment but then when i turned
when i got it back i got like six or
seven thousand dollars back so it's like
i basically didn't even pay for anything
the whole time it was like a wash right
like so i got to drive this really nice
car and got all this money back um so
there's there's things where there's
places i've spent money blown money
but yeah yeah i think it's probably the
interior decorating but that's not like
a very fun wasteful experience that
would make a fun story no i feel it i
want to show up my whole entire room
right now but the thing that holds me
back from spending all this money is
because i'm simply too lazy
but that's a good thing i think because
it's like this is not like this is a
rental house this is not like when you
buy if you buy like a nice condo or if
you buy a house or whatever you like
you're gonna
you're gonna have a reason to and then
it'll be worth it yeah and you're not
wasting that money now on these like
temporary i'm gonna have a single
mattress on the floor
at least we can resell our stuff you
can't because you don't even get them
yours is embarrassing
kickstarter yeah oh ours we can get like
maybe you know a little bit of money
back but i can still sell my sheet of
butter pumpkin i can sell my [ __ ] in
this
yeah the day i get it oh my god it's not
happening he's a day he's not dude he's
just smoking cigarettes somewhere he's
watching tv he's not working he's like
like an old white dad who's like just
really passionate about his pump and
there's no reason why it can't work he
just can't get it to work no no no it's
not that it's not working is that the
parts yeah i sound like his
representative why are you sticking up
for this video because
his uh updates are so thorough and i
think i only spent like 40 bucks on this
pump like it wasn't like
like a hundred dollars like it wasn't a
lot of money
but the amount of effort to steal 40
bucks from me is like nah you're like
impressed by the stories he's able to
tell of why he came
the
product updates from china that were
because he's getting parts over there
and then kovid did like a huge stop on
the production
so i don't know it seems like we're
close to the finish it it's the
finishing line i really hope that i
finally get my peanut butter pop the day
she gets it she finds out she's allergic
to peanut butter
i've gone through you know those costco
size because that's what this pump is
for it's like for the big jars
i've gone through like six of them
already and since i purchased this pump
and i'm like oh needs all the [ __ ]
scraping and i have to scrape i just got
my pop um okay
worst haircut i've ever received
oh i know exactly worst haircut
i have two actually no there's two worse
haircuts so one when i was a child my
mom cut my hair like an actual man like
a boy like he had a shave like you had a
fade i had well not a fade because this
is the 90s so they actually do fade
i
think i have a photo somewhere but she
cut it so short that i remember that i
was oh because i had curls too like when
i was little i had these really
beautiful curls
and i don't remember why she cut it but
she did and she then
we went to go take pictures at the photo
studio with my cousin because we had
similar dresses like someone bought us
dresses or something and i remember just
crying the whole time because i'm like i
look like a boy
oh and then also my curls just never
came back oh after that haircut my curls
didn't come back the same way like now
it's kind of wavy but i don't know how
to take care of my hair in order to
bring out the curls i've heard of the
curly curly curled method oh yeah but i
just haven't done it but anyway you
probably could yeah if you i could
probably get my clothes blades curls i
feel like your hair probably could do
that yeah and then the second bad
haircut was when that year that i lived
in mexico when i was 15 my sister was
going to esthetician school oh no and so
she used me as a model once so
what she did was she dyed my hair bright
bright red but the way she parted my
hair was like like if you picture like a
star with the five points
like the start like the
the fifth point was supposed to be in
the back yeah but for some reason she
put it in the front so and i had like
bright red bangs
and like and then okay so it's a star
right and then a circle
this idea is just so trashy yeah
with the rest of us like it sounds
pretty cool though okay so look it's a
star right and then you you get a circle
you
the oh my god why can't i explain this
the inside of the circle and the bottom
of the star is the same color so it's
like a black or a dark brown
but the points are all bright bright red
so it looks like streaks
when you have your hair down but she put
the fifth point right here so it was
like bright red right in my face so
that's that was the dye job yeah now the
haircut what she did is like she created
a mushroom in my hair
so it was so puffy up here wow and down
here was like it was almost like a
mullet
like it looked really bad please tell me
i don't have a picture
i was crying so much and i felt like
like now i kind of feel bad because she
was you know she's a student she was
trying to learn whatever but i was
crying so much i'm like this is the
worst haircut of my life oh my god i was
like i look like a mother
like a poisoned red mushroom yeah
literally
oh man i wish i had pictures
and it took forever for that so like you
know how i had
the
thin part was like above my shoulders so
to get hair to grow past your shoulders
like for me at least it would take
forever to get my hair to go past so i
literally felt like i had like a
mushroom hairstyle for like the longest
time
you were dealing with that for like so
that's hilarious yeah holy [ __ ] and they
can dye it back to brown oh yeah because
she bleached it to get it that bright
bright red she was like if i dye it like
it's gonna fry your hair or something i
don't know like she was learning
something
but yeah i was just like wow this is i
have to walk off oh wait i think i do
have a picture of him please oh [ __ ] oh
god i think i do let me pull it up okay
do you have it on your phone yeah
because it's in my photo bucket
my mom for some reason cut my hair
really short and then i have these
really short bangs so it was just like
an ugly like you know kind of like a
bold mullet kind of
looking thing typical
no it wasn't that funny though yeah i
had the same thing
short all the way up to my earlobes i
think we just all had that shitty
[ __ ] shorts yeah and then like they
would cut the banes i was like oh [ __ ]
it's not even and they cut it shorter
yeah oh no it's like all the way up here
but the worst part is my aunt left a
[ __ ] rat tail ah i remember this
right now you're talking about
[ __ ] the rat tail dude i cried for days
you finally cut it off who the hell
decides to give a little girl a rat tail
and the funny sounds kind of hot
though when you're like six years old
and then i remember um i finally got her
to cut it off and this is like the
weirdest story i finally got her to cut
it off and i go to school and this girl
named ellen tells me hey
um my cousin thinks you're really cute
because he loves girls with rat tails
i was like [ __ ]
[ __ ] this place but
the rat tail was actually kind of cool i
remember like during that week that i
had the rat sale you know like how i
like at school assemblies you sit on the
floor
and then so i would sit on the floor but
i was so afraid of people seeing my rat
tail i would sit like this though oh
you're like talking like shirts wrong
with her yeah
tuck it in the back of your shirt
and then the rest of your hair is back
there too
yeah because i was so embarrassed and
like i was so sore because it was such a
long assembly the whole time
it was [ __ ] dumb oh my god that's
hilarious those are both pretty [ __ ]
rough that's really funny yours is
[ __ ] up yeah [ __ ] red mushrooms i
know i'm trying to find the pictures i
just need so many sub albums i don't
know where he's gonna give us cards that
she's gonna give you you know red tail
girl had a red
mullet mushroom you had a poisonous
mushroom on your head for like a year
no predator animal would come near you
dude i'm not gonna get any cards in this
game i swear to go oh my god tiff is
struggling you guys are a struggle bus
all the way man crazy stories oh man i
really don't know i gotta try to look up
look that up and then like get casey to
put it in in post because that's
hilarious i know i know i have it in
here somewhere i'll look later
did you know that an estimated 5 billion
plastic hand soap and cleaning bottles
are thrown away each year that's a lot
guys and also most of it's just water so
like it's just really heavy to ship so
why are we doing that blue land has
actually come up with a way to fix this
problem they're on a mission to
eliminate the single-use plastics by
reinventing home essentials that are
good for you and the planet their
innovative tablet refill solution takes
up 10 times less space than a
traditional bottle and their powerful
formulas keep your home clean and
smelling amazing the idea is simple grab
one of the beautiful forever bottles
fill it with warm water drop in the
tablet and get cleaning refills are only
two dollars and you don't have to buy a
new plastic bottle every time you run
out you can even set up a subscription
so you never run out and you save even
more when you buy in bulk they have like
almost everything you could think of
that you need for your home hand soap
toilet cleaner laundry tablets all the
different types of cleaning solutions i
actually love the dishwasher tablets
it's great i love every single product
with their clean essentials kit which
has everything you need to get started
they come in refreshing signature scents
like iris agave fresh lemon eucalyptus
mint and for a limited time the hand
soap also comes in some new refreshing
scents strawberry rhubarb citrus
patchouli and coconut palm right now you
can get 15 off your first order when you
go to blueland.com big mood that's 15
off your first order of any blue land
products at blueland.com
big mood one more time that's
blueland.com
big mood uh next card worst job i've
ever had worse job
oh i had one
when i was living in orange county i
used to work at this
bar it's like a vietnamese bar it was
called yo-yo cafe because vietnamese
people name whatever the [ __ ] you wanted
now
um it was run by this woman uh we'll
call her v
so it was run by this woman and her um
her husband omar
and he was like the nicest dude like
filipino dude you know i think he was
like a pilot or something but and she
was like this vietnamese woman in her
late 40s maybe he was so in love with
her they were engaged she was so in love
with her that you know he gave her
whatever she wanted so um she wanted a
like a vietnamese bar like a
drinking place
and so
i responded to her
like she just opened it up i responded
to her craigslist posting like we're
opening up this bar we need waitresses
and i applied for it because i speak
vietnamese fluently and then so i
applied for it
got the job helped her open the um the
the bar
and things were going fine it was you
know it's fine but you know how you get
that feeling where you just kind of know
someone starts to not like you and i was
like this is she like it felt like v was
starting to not like me which is
like why i've been here since day one
i've been helping and i told one of the
um other waitresses that and the
waitress went and told her that i was
like oh
so v pulls me aside one day she's like i
heard that you think i had a little
finger yeah she little fingered me and
she was like i heard that you think that
i don't like you why and i was like oh
because i feel like you've been treating
me differently i don't understand why
she's like no no i still like you
and then uh the next week she fired all
the girls and brought in
new
older
kind of
not as great looking girls and i was
like this is weird what the [ __ ] going
on but that didn't work out so she
begged us to come back so we can she
fired you too you were part of the fire
too but she begged me to come back after
like two weeks or so um it's because she
thought
her husband was flirting with all of us
or like we're trying to get us
in the case of the insecure
yeah because
it turns out she was cheating on him
with one of her customers
she's like those messy drunken older
vietnamese women that never let go of
their younger years oh yeah so she would
always like be in there drinking with
customers and stuff and like she like
started um seeing one of them and that's
like so her
guilty conscious made her project yeah
and that's why she started treating us
very differently and i was like i knew
it like you are treating us differently
one day we came into work and
like it was my time to clock in but the
restaurant was or the bar was closed and
i was like what the [ __ ] why is it not
open like she's supposed to be there i
looked in the window it was closed all
the tv all the tvs on the walls were
gone oh and i was like what's going on
so i called up omar
and i was like hey
what's going on it's not open
she ran off with that dude damn she came
in she stole everything to sell it
there were times when people would pull
up to our restaurant or our bar and be
screaming at the car like you [ __ ]
always money [ __ ] because she had a
gambling problem damn here's a crazy
thing that was when i was like 21. when
i was 24 years old i was in hawaii with
my friends who were hanging out like
this like um local bar
and it was about closing time but i was
still there because my girlfriends were
bartenders there and then in walks two
people and i'm just sitting at the bar
drinking on my phone like not really
paying attention and then i hear this
[ __ ] annoying laugh that i can i will
recognize that laugh until the day
that's like janice from friends yes
i look up and it's v
and this like younger looking dude
and i look up and i was like oh my god
she looked at me she goes
oh my god gina
and i was like what the [ __ ]
and she was drunk and just like laughing
it up with this dude
and she was like i'm so sorry for what i
did and blah blah blah like i you know i
i had a problem i was like
and then um she's like i opened up a
bikini bar here in hawaii come work for
me i was like [ __ ] no oh hell no
absolutely not and then um i noticed she
had a fat rock on her finger
and and then she went to the bathroom
and then the guy was like hey so how do
you know her you know he was really nice
like how do you know her i was like
i used to work for her he goes and how'd
that go i was like it was [ __ ] awful
and he's like really i'm like yeah not
the greatest person in the world let me
just let you know that right now because
i was drunk yeah um and then i'm
surprised you didn't tell them the whole
story i didn't have time the [ __ ] was
in the bathroom you know i didn't want
to go
listen so she robbed everything yeah
you're all like ready to rap yeah
i'm like well save yourself man save
yourself i see an innocent person i want
to save them yeah from horrible people
the dude looks so young it looks like he
was in his late 20s or something jesus
yikes yeah that's my worst job damn
yeah that sucks and front desk at a
hotel people in the hotel suck
i think my workshop wasn't a real job i
just kind of got sucked into um selling
knives for cutco
that [ __ ] like correct like i can't
stand when people tell me no so like
after i don't think i only did it for
like two weeks i really guys were good
though the knives were pretty good like
my dad walk around with a briefcase of
knives essentially you don't walk around
though you like make appointments it's
like a like a pyramid scheme or whatever
so you obviously like you start with
your friends and family and then try to
buy
knives yourself or they give you like a
kit but yeah i think it's like like you
can use their kit which is like a whole
thing but then like you buy only like
one or two of them and that's how you
kind of buy into it but then you have
like a sample of like the whole thing
but yeah i know i just i that that was
pretty shitty he said you said i can't
stand when people say no what did you do
or say you're like no it's just like
you're trying to demonstrate
you're trying to demonstrate how good
the knives work or whatever and you like
have to cut a rope and like show how
quickly the knife can cut the like
through a [ __ ] piece of rope and like
all this [ __ ] and be like okay well
yeah i don't i don't know if that i
necessarily need like a 500 set of
knives right now and you know and for me
i'm just like
i need a sale you know and like i think
at one point like i had um i can't
picture you in a sales position i know
it's just so bad and then so i at one
point i i think i did a whole
presentation and i had an order in that
i thought was going to be pretty good
and then like a few weeks or a few days
later they called me like oh i spoke to
my husband and he said we need to we
have to cancel it and then like that day
i quit i was like i [ __ ] know this
[ __ ] yeah oh thank god you didn't put
way too much into it no it was only a
few weeks because i was like i just
can't
do sales like it's probably one of the
worst things too and also it being like
a pyramid scheme type of thing where you
like kind of start with people you know
it's like kind of embarrassing to like
embarrass yourself in front of people
that you kind of know so that sucked but
that was people get so sucked into those
it's crazy and it's all good about all
the time everywhere yeah you have to
like it's like a cult like you kind of
get trapped in this cult mind of like if
you're not making money it's your fault
you're like damn everyone is you know
a potential target for a sale and that's
just so embarrassing yeah i remember one
of my friends got into like a pyramid
scheme
and one day he was like
gina what's your dream car
because i'm going to make it big next
month i'm going to make so much money
i'm going to buy you your car oh and i
was like okay sweet no i ain't doing it
delusional he said that's queen that's
queen it's cute sweet so cute
over here making up words
that's queen girl
so he's like yeah i'll buy you the car
of your dreams or whatever because like
um it was i was dating his cousin he
just wanted to help everyone out like it
was sweet you know he's like next next
next year or next month i'm gonna make
so much money like okay cool
never heard about it again
there's a few people on facebook i
remember like after i had gone through
my pyramid scheme like deal and like
kind of realized like oh this
multi-level marketing [ __ ] is just
[ __ ]
um or well that one i mean i guess is
probably like one of the least offensive
ones because it actually like you are
actually trying to sell the knives and
not just
get people to sign up to also so
like you physically are trying to sell
knives but like there was another friend
of ours like on facebook who like we
could tell he went like head first like
and he just started going crazy and me
and this other girl would be commenting
under his stuff like hey bro like i
don't know if you realize but this is
just a pyramid scheme you might want to
kind of back off of it and he would just
go ape [ __ ] like doing all the
haters blah blah blah yeah yeah it was
just like then i
couldn't talk to him again after that
yeah it's it's terrible because it's
predatory and destructive and it
destroys communities and it's ridiculous
yeah yeah
that's true another shitty job that i
had was i was a um i had to sit at the
top of a water slide at this like
because i used to live on an island
right like i'm in port aransas where i
grew up as an island and so there's like
a bunch of little resorts and stuff so i
just sit at the top of a water slide and
make sure the kids go down foot first
that sounds fun but it was i started
this job in the winter time so i was
like the pool was warm it was like
heated or something so kids were still
out there like swimming but it was like
maybe i don't know 60 outside so but so
it would just be like overcast and kind
of ugly and i was up high right so it's
kind of cold because of the wind and i'm
just sitting there in this thing and
like i couldn't like really do anything
to pass the time like i couldn't have a
book or anything because like you
basically have to always be watching
these kids i wasn't a lifeguard but i
just had to watch them and make sure
they go down foot first i couldn't last
like two three weeks at the job either
it was just so
[ __ ] boring yeah that is yeah and the
weather was terrible when i started it
so i didn't like it i totally picked
right now yeah i would want to quit too
yeah yeah [ __ ] that i don't want to be
responsible for any kid's stupid [ __ ]
safety
yeah and they're all annoying too like
yeah little kids when they're with their
friends and they think they're hot oh
[ __ ] they're just so annoying
and like especially little boys are the
worst
um i haven't had many jobs in my
lifetime it must be nice um
like because i've been doing this for
the past 10 years
i'm only 30. i started working at 16.
yeah it's not a lot of jobs like i
worked at hometown buffet i thought we
were the same age no i'm in my 30s is
what i mean like you're already 30.
it's 2019 it's 20 22 so i'm 32. what do
you remember i remember 89 but november
of 8th november 29th of 89.
you're going to be okay 30 i'm going to
be 33 in november yes in november okay
of this year you old [ __ ] trying to act
like you're 31 i forgot
no i always the way i remember my age
now is by the year yeah that's how i
know you have to do math now no it's not
math it's just the year 30 years 22 it's
i'm 32. yeah if it's 23 then the 33 yeah
oh yeah
like in 2008 i was 18.
like it's easy to remember because of
that yeah anyway um until november yeah
until november then that's when oh i
used this one
and you have no idea how old you were
no when i was really little i remember i
think it was my mom who said this which
is kind of sweet i guess is that um like
i remember i asked her i'm like mom it's
1995
and i'm five but now i'm gonna be six
but it's not 1996 yet and she was like
oh it's because your birthday brings in
the new year oh
my god that's cute so i have to turn
sixth first and then the the year turns
into 1990's that's cute but after santa
comes we have to wait yeah yeah he's the
one that brings the birthday yeah
no but anyway yeah jobs i don't know
like i've i haven't really hated my jobs
like i don't know i worked at the
hospital for like five years
before doing youtube and i really
enjoyed the actual work of it i just
hated the politics of the hospital like
it felt like being in high school all
over yeah there's different jobs that
like the people yeah it was the people
that yes it was the people that killed
it for me and all i mean the environment
part of it it didn't help that the
department i worked at was always in the
basement of the hospital so and i i
tended to always work the later shift
like 3 p.m to 11 p.m so i felt like i
never really saw the sunlight and that
was like the worst thing about the job
but but actually the worst thing was the
people but the actual job so yeah i
don't know i don't really have
a worse job really all right it's
between you and me yeah i've had a
shitload of jobs too or worse jobs i
also worked as a i worked as a um
a hostess at a strip club for a short
period of time
they're nice i like the strippers i do
not like the men because like i would i
had a whole like uniform on so like i
wasn't naked or anything like that but
the um the clientele were pretty shitty
oh i'm sure so that was a pretty
terrible job which is like the worst
worse the waterslide one
wait what would you say before gosh i
also had i worked for a little while
typical knives oh the cut code yeah i
worked at a sausage making company as a
bookkeeper once oh okay
what the [ __ ] i always say you don't
want to know how the sausage is made
yeah i've had a lot of jobs like a ton a
ton of jobs and they've all been kind of
like whack okay i think you're right
because you fell for an mlm
here you go
well yours was [ __ ] wild with the
lady that's i mean but the actual job
wasn't
too bad
it's really interesting working at a bar
when you don't drink
but then the best part of that job was
the the kitchen lady the one that was
cooking she was this old vietnamese lady
and i called her mom
i lost contact with her because the
restaurant shut down out of nowhere yeah
and i lost contact with her so that
sucked mm-hmm yeah god i've had so many
jobs it's crazy when i think about it
like i've had a lot of jobs a lot of
crazy different jobs yeah
it's nice
uh worst wardrobe malfunction wardrobe
functional wardrobe one time i was go go
dancing oh yeah i know the story oh when
your lip was hanging out
and a guy came up to me and he's like
waving me down like what's up he goes
hey i just want to let you know that i
can
one of your lips is hanging out and i
was like oh [ __ ] sorry
i still don't understand how you didn't
feel the wind um because on your vagina
lip true i don't know like it's well
it's hot and muggy in there yeah and i
wore like double layer panties you know
like one small painting like thong
underneath and then the bikini bottom on
that on there so i'm used like the thong
underneath to maybe like ride up but i
didn't realize both bro was riding up
saying oh thank you thank you oh yeah
that sucks
that does suck and i remember one time i
was going dancing one night
and then i looked over to my other
google she's like
your whole tail is out you're moving my
one like half my nipples out i was like
oh [ __ ] thanks
[ __ ] hell um i remember one when i
was touring with um
nitto tires when we win one round like
whatever rounds that we win they spray
us like the we're standing up in the
podiums and like the winner of our team
like sprays champagne everywhere so i
got champagne on me and we were
transporting from because we traveled
from state to state so they would take
care of the uniform and trans transport
it well
uh they forgot to wash my uniforms when
i opened it it was mold all over the
uniform
[Music]
and it was show day so i had to bring it
to the bathroom and i washed it with
like dawn dish soap no dried it under
the hand dryer i don't know but i made
it work oh so like you got the stains
out yeah i got the stains out but
there's probably internal
somewhere you were breathing all kinds
of crazy sports did you get sick after
that not at all oh crazy well just wait
till like i'm 80 and see if i have
alzheimer's or something
something's working
it's growing oh yeah taking us out but
it's here
i don't know i have two but they're not
like i kind of don't want to tell them
they're both kind of like
no okay
whatever you're comfortable with yeah i
don't think i have yeah i can't remember
any hooters wardrobe modifications
not really those are pretty secure i
feel like yeah it's always it's all
because you have so you have a you have
pantyhose on right that are like thick
and tan which obviously doesn't match my
skin tone so that was kind of ridiculous
the opposite for the black girls like it
they still have [ __ ] tan really a lot
of yeah like until they finally started
giving them like the black skinned ones
i was like why are we all wearing these
[ __ ] like it doesn't match my skin it
doesn't match her skin we all look
[ __ ] ridiculous yeah this same tan
color and then you have the thick ass
socks those hideous oh the 1980s tube
socks
when you go in like the manager lines
you up like before we start work and he
does a whole outfit check fingernail
check like everything like head to toe
fingernail check two you have to get
checked before
peek-a-boo
i don't think so because he was just
very dismissive of all of us all the
time like he was bothered by our
existence you know what i mean so that's
why you have to play it off it could be
it could be him like fronting you know
what i mean but no like yeah so like
fingernails if we had anything on it
like it could be chipped or like so like
everything had to be like clean and like
done and stuff like that so yeah no more
no
not functions there i would not be okay
like i would not be able to survive i'm
sure i've like shown my ass in a club on
accident like that for a dress or
something but nothing that really was
enough to remember yeah i don't really
have anything i don't have any titties
so they don't ever pop out
all right i'll keep this card yeah yeah
you definitely get that i'll keep this
one you showed your vagina up to a bunch
i know
god bless that guy wherever he is i hope
he's happy
uh worst date i've ever been on i did
have a pretty shitty one recently
um did i tell you this one the guy who
like thought he was being cool and suave
so like there was a guy that i met a few
gosh i want to say it was earlier this
year
he um
we met out and he seemed fine he told me
he was like a real estate flipper or
whatever which is kind of like what my
brother does i'm like yeah that seems
fine like not the type of guy would
normally date but like
so like a little bit more blue collar
right like he would be the one that not
like the investor who has the money but
the guy that would kind of like make it
happen so i'm like okay so i thought he
would be a nice decent guy but then when
we're out and we're drinking at one
point he's like
he's he turned to me and he's just like
so what's a nice girl like you doing out
with a guy like me oh god what about
yourself and i was like
what the [ __ ]
and i was like wait what
what does that mean why is that so funny
what i was like
huh
like what are you what are you doing
yeah who are you yeah what do you mean
like what do you mean
yeah
cause like by all accounts you made it
through my first [ __ ] like level of
like judgment i guess where i was like
okay you seem to have a nice job you
look nice you look clean whatever and
then all of a sudden he busts that out
so i was just like
huh what does that mean he just told him
and then he and then he
then when i started pressing him like
what do you mean
like what is that yeah i think he
thought that that was sexy oh god like
he was a bad boy yeah but i just decided
to leave after that so yeah
how did he respond to your grilling he
was just like avoiding it or trying to
play it off i don't remember because
i started like the wheel started
spinning in my head so a lot of it like
i kind of blacked out because like my
rage kind of started to kick in you know
he triggered you yeah he triggered me so
i was like what does that mean what do
you mean
what are you
uh and then so yeah that i was just like
no
peace so that ended pretty quickly yeah
it did not go as he thought it probably
would which would be like me being like
oh my god oh you're a bad boy
how do you want to spank me
can you like sound clips please
i use that for my stream every time i
get a donation
spank me
yeah he that that did not work out for
him well at all that's a terrible thing
horrible yeah um but yeah what was my
thinking yeah i think he really thought
he was like rico suave and that that was
gonna turn me like a bad boy but i was
like oh but i guess you haven't met a
girl that's like me then because
that is an absolute turn red flag yeah
like red flag like maybe when i was
younger i would have laughed at that and
kind of thought like oh
you know like uh yeah
i'm a bad girl too you know like
you think i'm gonna change him i'm a i'm
not a nice girl i'm a bad girl too oh my
god
i thought i'm so cringy though
it's like he saw that line in a movie
he's like i'm gonna try that next time
right i don't know what he thought that
was gonna do but i'm like i'm too out of
all of the bars and all the work
that's all i had to say
i mean if he just didn't let that come
out of his mouth he you know you know
but i'm glad he did that's funny how are
you i haven't had many dates i didn't
really date very much in my lifetime um
but the one date that i can remember
that i'm like well i guess that was
pretty bad is um i dated the so i was in
high school
and i went on a date with this
guy who was the older brother of a
friend and so this guy he was in the
marines and
yep nope
instant no
no so he he had i think he had been
deployed or he was about to be deployed
or something oh i think he was about to
be deployed and so
he was
he ended up taking me to the move the
local movie theater that had two dollar
tuesdays like for the movie theater so
i'm like okay cool let's go watch a
movie i can't even remember what the
movie was
but after the movie date he took me to
jack-in-the-box drive-through to get
dinner
and then at the parking lot of the
jack-in-the-box as we were eating our
dollar menu items
i was uh he was telling me about his as
we were eating our dollar menu items
because i'm like come on bro you're
older like yeah yeah i don't expect much
from people clearly but like at least a
tiny like at least not the dollar man
it's not the dollar man
so uh as we're eating he's like he's
showing me the marine songs and chanting
to them
oh
god where's the card where's the card oh
well yeah you can go ahead i don't even
need to tell any stories
[ __ ]
there is nothing gonna top that
seriously i gotta finish i'm not done so
then
he's doing his hoorahs and stuff and
like just going out cringey oh i can't
even
hear the rest of this
okay you're getting married this is a
trigger warning for jess be prepared
okay
it gets worse
so after like hearing all that stuff
also i'm like a horny 16 year old so i'm
like all right we'll make out so we're
making out but then after he's like okay
so you know how i'm in the military and
we get benefits so
we can get married and i can get this
much money and blah blah and we could
get this much money and then he was like
and if we have a kid oh my god we'll get
double and so what did you say i told
you yeah i told you
yeah he literally was like proposing
marriage to a 16 year old at the jack in
the box drive-through
after like literally we're on our first
date guys i don't even need to say a
goddamn word god bless those crayons
oh my god crazy holy [ __ ] that's
amazing yeah go ahead and keep that card
i want to hear your story
uh
worst day it was probably one guy who
wouldn't stop like whenever i say
something like he'll ask me a question
and then mansplain my answer to me what
and the whole time would not blink while
he's talking
it's so like i'll be like jess what's
your favorite color blue okay yeah see i
can see why your favorite color is blue
because like the same thing as your eyes
which i can get that because you
probably really like that color because
you see it every day you know so yeah i
get that and just like not blink is that
i think that's his way of validating i
don't know but it's really comes off
really like authoritative yeah really
weird and i just didn't blink while
talking i'm like this is [ __ ] creepy
like he had to
figure out
why everything about you was what it was
yeah something okay and it was it's
strange and it's just like you're like
we don't need a background for you yeah
well we don't need reasons for
everything but can you please blink
you're
just to see if they work
imagine he doesn't like it all but he
just pulls out eye drops
or he has like the reptilian
that would make more sense based on the
way he was [ __ ] talking it's like he
was gathering data
[ __ ] centurion
his
[Laughter]
very
oh so it's him
or um
there was a guy that like earlier this
year uh he he sat there and talked about
nfts for like 20 or 30 minutes oh geez
yeah like that's his whole personality
that's less cringe oh that's less
cringey than a guy like doing the
[ __ ] hoorah [ __ ] right yeah that's
really [ __ ] cringy
um because he had like one of those like
super expensive like board ape
board so this is recent yeah this is
like in jan feb personally so before the
recent game yeah it was well i mean it
was like a like someone that i had known
like 10 years ago and we just so
happened to be an era let's go grab
you're trying to give it a shot no we
were never interested in each other and
this was like i figured so was it a date
no it was like it started off as a
platonic and then was like oh you're
actually pretty cute so we were jerking
getting to know each other and then the
nft started i was like all right
i'm good i haven't had so many bad dates
with like strangers as much as like my
boyfriend's turned into shitty people
over time yeah that's like my worst
my worst dates are with my actual
ex-boyfriends i would say
where like [ __ ] went crazy
damn yeah we're gonna go ahead with the
marine that is yeah hilarious
holy [ __ ] i could see why you didn't
date much after that yeah
oh my like this is what dating is let me
pick one because i don't know if i'll
have anything
i'm trying to see because i haven't
really had any stories you know girl get
some cards i don't have any memories
it's the hard part
there's like songs yeah he was chanting
what they chant during the marching or
whatever yeah like he was no but he
literally put it in a cd one two three
four like it was a cd
playing this music
yeah geez a cd he burned his skull
yeah what makes you think someone wants
to marry you if you're buying dollar
menu [ __ ]
all right
like he wants to have sex the only
marine chance like the key match sounds
like my aunt's husband actually
she was only allowed to listen to that
like big band [ __ ]
damn really [ __ ] yeah he passed away
wait big ben jazz because i love big
benjamin no but it's like in like
military music and stuff like i say i
don't have any stories this is tough for
me i can't wait another date i can't do
i remember because i like i said i
have very limited dates it was this guy
that i really really liked and we were
supposed to go to a house party together
with two other friends
and back then like the address to the
party was given
through a voicemail giving you
directions
like if you're coming from south la you
take the 110 north or whatever so we
called the number and they were like
they gave us the wrong freeway they said
i think they said like 110 west
and it's only north and south but we
were up and down the 110 like where's
west oh my god so the whole night we
just spent the whole [ __ ] night
looking for 110 west oh my god and then
it ended up getting so late they were
like yeah let's just go home we can't
find this party like we were like we
spent our whole day
on the freeway i would be pissed because
i get carsick also yeah
but i like this guy so much i'm like i'm
just happy to be in this car with you
yeah that's cute you don't have anything
for this i i don't have any memory
recall on any of those
i'm too lazy to turn my body so anyways
that's the rest i'm sorry that's the end
of our episode thank you guys for
watching oh wait how many cars did you
guys get oh i got two i got one i got
five oh yeah okay i'm the best
storyteller all right thanks for
watching you guys i hope you guys liked
our stories uh hopefully we'll play this
again next time for more stories some
dumb stories uh make sure you guys check
out our
sponsored answers and make sure you like
this video subscribe to us um and
comment below you know some answers that
you have and um
go marines
[Laughter]
[Music]
you